ce habitants de cette commune s'étaient
mobilisés pour que cette maternité ne
ferme pas c'est ce qui va être le cas
pourtant et du coup les femmes enceintes
pourront accoucher que à 50 2 km en
allant à châtellerault ouvert à 60 km en
allant à châteauroux tout ça est
évidemment un problème
écoutez ce qu'en pense jean luc
mélenchon le président de la france
insoumise
il a réagi justement sur cette fermeture
pour toute cette zone est bien il faut
aller à 60 km pour atteindre une
maternité 60 km bon je rappelle que la
circulation est limitée à 80 heures
maintenant
bah c'est une c'est une heure quoi à peu
près 1
parce que c'est pas comme ça comme une
flèche donc c'est une heure alors les
gens disent mais dis donc
vous avez perdu les eaux et après vous
monter dans une voiture pour faire une
heure de route
vous avez la probabilité de que le gamin
né dans la voiture et commence à être un
peu élevée pour finir donc les gens ont
peur dont raison voilà je suis passé à
chaque fois mais là les arguments de
jean luc mélenchon l'a vraiment
absolument imparable
mais comme la situation est peut-être un
petit peu plus compliqué que ce qu'il
décrit
voici maintenant la parole donnée à la
défense et à dire agnès buzyn la
ministre de la santé il ya quelques
jours sur france info elle parlait de ce
sujet et elle disait en gros et ben oui
on doit fermer cette maternité parce
qu'on n'a pas le choix
et voici pourquoi problème que nous
avons cette prochaine
nationale nous manquons d'obstétriciens
avait beaucoup de maternité aujourd'hui
ne sont pas capables de remplir leur
liste de garde
donc il ya des journées entières ou des
nuits entières dans lequel si les femmes
vient d'accoucher
il n'y a pas d'obstacle tri siens pour
faire une césarienne en urgence j'ai
demandé un audit sur cette maternité qui
étaient dans ce cas là tous les médecins
partait à la retraite il n'y avait plus
d'obstacle siens et l'audit qui nous a
été donné montrent en fait de très
mauvaises pratiques dans cette maternité
avec une méconnaissance des procédures
d'urgence donc au delà même de la liste
des gardes qui n'est pas rempli c'est
une maternité dangereuse nicolas vidal
en fait ils ont tous les deux raison
quoi ce sauf qu'on se dit a priori c'est
ici un risque de danger pour les femmes
qui accouchent alors il faut la fermer
cette matière c'est compliqué parce que
pour avoir lu pas mal de choses au sujet
ces dernières heures
il ya pas mal de gens aussi qui sont
pour la couverture cette maternité qui
sont petits qui sont pas d'accord avec
agnès buzyn et qui disent que c'est de
la libye concrètement moi la question je
pose aujourd'hui et je suis aussi un peu
d'accord ils ont aimé longchamp
effectivement sur ce kilométrage et on
pourra parler le prix des carburants
également parce que ça que verse
fraîcheur c'est finalement à 60
kilomètres ça peut faire très cher mais
ce que je veux dire par là c'est ce que
la maternité la question et je la pose
simplement est-ce que la maternité doit
être doit être indexée sur un seuil de
rentabilité
aujourd'hui et est ce que pour moi pour
répondre à cette question c est vous
l'avez dit ces sujets ce corps bord
c'est un peu aussi le mépris de cette
france périphérique
voilà c'est un mépris de la classe
d'apprentis une claque à chaque menace
est ce qu'on doit faire rentrer la
logique marchande dans justement là au
sein du service public et aux simples la
thématique des 3d mais il n'y a pas de
médecin il ya plus de pression que ce
que vous voulez la difficulté
la difficulté j'y vais je vais être
courtes ne vous inquiétez pas je vois
que la parole est demandée la difficulté
en effet c'est celle en fait des risques
et du danger que ça présente et ils sont
doubles et c'est un petit peu compliqué
c'est à dire qui est à la fois la
distance parce qu'on sait que lorsque la
distance est supérieur à 45 minutes
ça pose des problèmes de sérieux
problèmes de danger et de risques à la
fois pour la mère et pour l'enfant mais
il ya également
il ya également le statut de ces
maternités qui font lorsqu'elles font
par exemple moins de 300 accouchements
par an c'est souvent le critère qui est
retenu ne sont pas présents des risques
ne sont pas assez habitués ne rencontre
pas assez de cas d'urgence et il ya de
plus en plus de maternité qui sont
aujourd'hui d'obstétriciens attaqué
parce que parce qu'il ya des excédents
des accidents médicaux
donc c'est un rapport de la cour des
comptes que je crois de 2015 évoqué sa
non pas sous l'angle marchand qui qui
plaît à certains mais sur le plan
sanitaire et sur le plan des risques en
expliquant qu' on ne pouvait pas fermer
les yeux là dessus donc ça c'est un
point important et il me semble un petit
peu dangereux de le balayer en
expliquant que
il faut garantir coûte que coûte et
maintenir ses maternités et dans les
espaces ruraux
parce que sinon ce couperet de voilà de
toute une partie du service public
réponse nuancée j'observe ça avec un peu
d froid pour tout vous dire c'est à dire
que là on est vraiment face à
l'administration de la santé l'économie
dirigée de la santé d'un côté on a des
gens qui nous disent bon ben là on un
service de piètre qualité on va perdre
des maternités et puis de l'autre on à
la ministre qui qui en charge du numerus
clausus qui le dit a pas assez
d'obstétriciens donc c'est elle qui
limite l'offre de deux médecins et puis
on à mélenchon qui est sain qui
s'improvisent obstétricien qui nous dit
oui ça c'est sais c'est pas normal on
aujourd'hui le lait les besoins de santé
ça ne peut pas être géré de manière
centralisée par l'état c'est pas quelque
chose qui est possible on arrive à
londres des choses effroyables je te
coupe 10 secondes et je vous passe la
parole parce que aulas justement pose la
question sur sur twitter faire sauter le
numerus clausus pourrait-il régler ce
problème je pense que oui c'est
l'ouverture à la concurrence le numerus
clausus est une barrière à la
concurrence est limitée est longue des
médecins parce que nombre d'autres
techniciens en fait si l'on regarde le
chemin qui sont eux qui sont effectués
c'est un dessin vous pouvez mettre
autant de pression que vous voulez dans
la maternité il y aura pas forcément
plus être donc il ya un débat pour
savoir est ce que il ya suffisamment ou
pas de médecin est ce qu'il ya
suffisamment bas d'accouchement ce n'est
pas un ministère à paris qui a des
centaines de kilomètres qui va décider
de ça c'est quelque chose qui a géré de
manière locale
il faut décentraliser la question de la
santé l'ouvrir à la concurrence je
laissais se gérer sa part des mutuelles
laisser gérer sa part des associations
si vous voulez paquet de profits parce
que le profil vous fait vous fait hurler
mais non je suis désolé
justement la hurler le conflit c'est un
indicateur que vous rendez service
certains disent que dans la lah enfin
vous pouvez laborde et si vous voulez on
peut tout voir à travers ce filtre mais
là il n'est pas extrêmement pertinent
parce que le pr la première chose qui va
seulement vérifier ça va marcher
non c'est pas cette dichotomie elle
marche pas forcément c'est pas forcément
justement le profil a mais c'est aussi
d'abord la question de la santé et du
danger que vous le vouliez ou pas
il me paraît quand même premiers sur
cette question c'est parce que c'est
essentiel qu'il faut surtout pas le
laisser à la bureaucratie enfin là on
est on est face à des gens qui ne disent
cette maternité offre des services de
piètre qualité
laissons les gens faire mieux fin c'est
ça qui est ok et auchan l'urgence est là
on vous pose la question sur twitter un
vous l'avez vu sur votre écran les
petites maternités du pays ferment leurs
portes les unes après les autres faute
il empêcher ces fermetures et vous êtes
un peu plus des trois quarts à
considérer que oui il faut empêcher ces
fermetures olivier ravanello et ceci
votre point de vue oui aussi et je
trouve l'argument du service qui n'est
pas optimale comme pouvant justifier la
fermeture là aussi un argument où on
prend les choses un peu à l'envers c'est
à dire qu'à tout prendre entre un
obstétricien qui qui n'a pas rencontré
beaucoup de cas compliqués dans l'année
et le mari qui est sa femme à accoucher
dans la voiture je préfère encore un
obstétricien même s'il n'a pas vu
beaucoup de cas compliqués et au final
tout ça renvoie toujours à la question
de l'aménagement du territoire qui est
quelque chose qui a été complètement
laissés de côté on est face à une
situation économique qui nécessiterait
qu'on donne la possibilité à des gens de
pouvoir s'installer pouvoir plus vivre
dans des communes moins importante ou le
où le prix du logement est moins
important pour justement pouvoir amortir
des revenus qui sont en train de baisser
c'est une façon aussi de lutter contre
la paupérisation des classes moyennes de
permettre de pouvoir vivre à châteauroux
ailleurs dans de bonnes conditions et
pour vivre dans de bonnes conditions il
faut qu'ils aient des infrastructures
étatiques autour qui fonctionne il faut
qu'ils aient un hôpital il faut qu'on
puisse se dire bah tiens je vais avoir
des enfants dans cette région et ça va
pas être un problème sinon vous allez
avoir des grands pôles régionaux qui
vont devenir un peu surdimensionné avec
autour des grands déserts à la fois
médicaux mais pas seulement et des
grands déserts ruraux
donc je pense que ça fait partie des
dépenses qui ne peuvent pas justement
être rationnel
la fonction publique doit à certains
moments être rentable et à d'autres
moments ne pas l'être et qu'on ait une
vision d'ensemble où tout s'harmonise
oui mais il y a déjà des fonctions
publiques qui par définition est par
nature sont déficitaires et il faut
l'assumer il faut les regarder pour le
regardant nos voisins qui on va faire
des systèmes de santé qui sont bien plus
performant que le sytème de santé
français qui ont ouvert à la concurrence
avait pas dire qu'on fait n'importe quoi
ça veut dire qu'il ya des mécanismes qui
permettent de fournir des meilleurs
services parce qu'il ya des gens qui
peuvent proposer mieux si demain il ya
un entrepreneur qui veut créer une
clinique ou créer une maternité
eh bien il va être en concurrence
déloyale face à la face à le système
administré de santé c est donc il va
pouvoir proposer des nouveaux services
aux habitants de châteauroux voilà c'est
ça le problème le problème et il va
avoir du mal à recruter parce qu'il ya
un numerus clausus qui empêche le nombre
de médecins ça nous a pas échappé que
vous allez dans une clinique c'est au
prix d un peu plus cher ça c'est faux
une corps une fois c'est faux c'est à
dire que il faut pas croire que c'est
gratuit on paye avec nos impôts
donc le système de santé n'est pas
gratuit c'était quelque chose que de
demander ça aussi c'est pas la même
chose que de se poser cette employée de
charles doria ou de payer lui
directement ou de proposer à la
collectivité
je disais exactement et donc duré de
rééquilibrage ne sait pas résister
maintenant je le redis serait jeudi de
permettre aux mutuelles de concurrence
et de sécurité sociale de réduction des
coûts là derrière effectivement avec ce
déséquilibre territorial où l'on se
retrouve avec des herbes et nico qui
vont qui vont devenir de plus en plus
arides et ça pose un vrai souci pour nos
concitoyens les plus volumineux des
territoires des grandes villes et vous
l'avez dit des métropoles et des des
centres médicaux performant et ça c'est
un vrai problème de fond on pourra
comparer quand même que la france est le
pays je crois du monde aujourd'hui à
part peut-être la corée du nord où la
dépense publique est la plus élevée donc
on peut pas dire que on manque de deux
oui mais elle n'est pas
proportionnellement et d'héritage et se
poser régulièrement la question de sks
que cette activité ce secteur nécessite
une intervention publique ou pas et pour
le cas de la santé je pense que oui je
voudrais vers les points de vue a qui
sont parvenus sur lefigaro.fr et puis
sur twitter wang ward qui nous dit
maintenir un service pour un
accouchement par jour ça en fait des
fonctionnaires de santé payé à peu faire
christian qui nous dit il faut supprimer
toutes ces maternités et les hôpitaux
non rentables et alors christian le nil
et sur la ligne il est sur la ligne de
l'iref
on veut des économies on voit des
économies ou pas si j'étais aux finances
goethe à gré au sabre dans la dépense
publique c'est peut-être l'année ses
provisions c'est une vision un peu
caricatural c'est à dire que moi je suis
pas pour qu'on coupe les finances et je
suis pas pour qu'on couple les budgets
l'important c'est d'ouvrir à la
concurrence encore une fois c'est ça qui
permettra à notre évaluation c'est comme
le loto du patrimoine de faire un loto
de la santé avec un appel alors je redis
citoyen je retire ce que j'ai dit sur
l'iref
et puis les intérêts des internautes des
internautes le chat du figaro live qui
nous disent il faut faire sauter le
numerus clausus et éviter que ce soient
des médecins étrangers qui viennent
compléter compléter ce monde il ya un un
mot qu'on n'a pas encore employé sur
ceux de dans ce débat c'est le mot de
démographie parce que la réalité aussi
c'est que il ya de moins en moins de
naissances en france et donc en
particulier dans ces régions peut-être
qu'on a moins besoin de maternité
accouche de ça si je peux te faire une
comparaison faisant une comparaison le
logement moi je suis incapable de dire
combien il faut de mètres carrés de
nouveaux logements à château et
n'importe quel ministre n'importe quel
énarques ne sera pas c'est des
promoteurs qui vont venir et qu'ils vont
dire on a un qui ont observé une demande
et qui parce qu'il ya cette demande vont
pouvoir peut-être faire une rentabilité
et qui vont se dire là on va construire
des nouveaux logements la loge ans entre
une vital c'est comme la santé et on
peut faire la même chose pour la santé
châteauroux ce qu'on appellera que c'est
la préfecture de l'indre ce que
désormais tous nos internautes savent
et bien justement ccc autres qui ont
peut être besoin d'être davantage et ds
que le gouvernement les aime
il y a